[Applaudissements]
on peut jouer pour gagner
où on peut jouer pour changer les règles
du jeu en tant qu'entrepreneur qui porte
aussi une cause
j'essaye de faire les deux et vous allez
voir c'est pas gagné d'avancé
mon terrain de jeu c'est la mode premier
préjugés justement c'est souvent vu
comme quelque chose de fun ludique léger
voire frivole et c'est vrai la mode est
un jeu avant tout un jeu avec soi qui
permet de se réinventer chaque jour se
créer un personnage joué des rôles
booster sa confiance en soi juste
s'amuser avec des tendances mais voir ça
juste comme quelque chose d'amusant et
dangereux car si la mode est un jeu les
femmes sont perdantes
tout simplement parce que la mode a un
impact considérable sur l'image qu'elle
renvoie des femmes
aujourd'hui cet impact est globalement
négatif les standards de beauté sont
limitées excluant et créer des complexes
à tout le monde
les hommes aussi des eaux la violence
des injonctions n'est pas tout à fait la
même
mais messieurs je m'adresse à vous ici
vous êtes aussi concernés oui oui vous
je suis féministe est désormais
entrepreneurs la mode est un sujet qui
me tient à coeur
de par son aspect créatif mais aussi de
par mon engagement
si je fais un rapide retour sur les
avancées en termes de féminisme les
dernières années du mois en cours du
dernier siècle
on a énormément gagné en droit droit de
vote droit à disposer de son corps doit
ouvrir un compte en banque ou droit
d'exercer lé même métier que les hommes
ok on partait de très très très très bas
il ya encore du chemin à faire
bien sûr il faut rester vigilant mais
globalement on va dans le bon sens
paradoxalement sur d'autres thématiques
plutôt de l'or du quotidien notamment la
mode
on n'a pas vraiment avancé on a même
plutôt reculé depuis les années 80 90
dans la mode la tendance des mannequins
en taille 34 et demi tout mouillé
photoshop tout ça n'a pas vraiment
contribué à améliorer l'image des femmes
qui sont plutôt défini avant tout par
leur corps et une seule forme de corps
dans la mode
on est dans le quotidien sur des images
qui sont avec nous en permanence et
c'est parfois plus difficile de mesurer
l'impact de ces images au quotidien ou
alors on prend cet impact tournant
mesure l'impact
rétrospectivement quand j'avais 10 ans
on m'a dit que je ressemblais à cindy
crawford à cause du grand modèle et je
me suis vite rendu compte que la
ressemblance s'arrêtait aux grains de
beauté parce que cindy crawford elle
avait des jambes interminables un ventre
parfait moi quand je m'asseyais mon
ventre faisait des plis à vous allez me
dire c'est normal le ventre de tout le
monde fait des plis quand il s'assoit
donc c'est un peu idiot comme complexe
et en même temps pas tant que ça parce
que les plis sur les ventres des
mannequins on les voit jamais il
n'existe pas soit ils sont pas
photographier ou alors ils sont
photoshopée donc à côté je me suis
trouvée grosse et j'ai fait mon premier
régime à cet âge là bon là je vous parle
de poids mais il ya tout un tas
d'injonction extraordinaire c'est un peu
plus tard quand j'avais 12 ans on m'a
fait remarquer que j'avais des poils sur
les bras que pour une fille ce n'était
pas normal du tout que c'était même
carrément dégueulasse
et ça j'ai vachement complexe et en fait
je vais porter des manches longues tout
le temps même en été heureusement j'ai
grandi en bretagne donc faut le dire il
fait quand même pas très très beau l'été
donc grâce à la météo je crois que mon
complexe est passé inaperçu et ça me
fait rire aujourd'hui mais mais ça me
faisait pas rire du tout à l'époque et
le lien avec la mode et très direct
parce que toutes et tous on se construit
par comparaison en regardant autour de
soi est-ce que je suis normal ok je suis
normal et pour savoir si je suis belle
je regarde le standard les top models
bon bah non alors fait normal mais je
suis pas belle aujourd'hui j'ai 27 ans
j'ai plus de complexes particulier qui
me gâche la vie au quotidien
pour autant comme 92% de française
je ne me sens pas belle ça veut pas dire
qu'on se sent tout moche mais
collectivement qu'on n'est jamais assez
bien pas mal mais pas belle 92% c'est
énorme comme c'est un chiffre qui vient
d'une étude d'offres qui est sorti à
deux ans alors on peut dire oui mais
c'est une marque attention même si on
leur laisse une marge d'erreur et
d'exagérations de malades ça reste
beaucoup trop et ça a des impacts des
répercussions en fait sur notre
quotidien sur mon quotidien des petites
répercussions comme à non mais là je mes
cheveux non je ressemble à rien je peux
pas prendre la parole en public comme ça
qui mises bout à bout vont avoir un
impact ou des répercussions plus lourde
il m'arrive encore de me dire de temps
en temps que je ne suis pas assez belle
pour réussir et c'est idiot un jeu je me
déteste quand je pense comme ça j mais
qu'est ce que tu te prends la tête sur
des trucs wef utile mais je ne suis pas
la seule je le vois aussi sur mes amis
il est fait de 25 ans de mode quand il
faut se mettre en maillot de bain sortir
se faire prendre en photo pas maquillée
il ya deux ans une de mes amies m'a dit
qu'elle ne voulait pas se marier parce
qu'elle ne se trouvait pas assez jolie
pour être le centre d'attention toute
une journée
je me déteste quand je pense comme ça et
je déteste toutes ces raisons qui ont
rendu mes copines malheureuse donc je
pourrais vous en parler pendant des
heures parce que c'est important de
comprendre d'où ça vient mais je crois
que notre rôle c'est pas seulement de
pointer du doigt et de montrer le
problème mais aussi d'agir de trouver
des solutions
fondamentalement être un game center je
crois que c'est agir selon ses
convictions sans oublier d'être
pragmatiques et adaptés la solution au
problème typiquement si la mode est le
problème
faut pas juste taper sur la mode il faut
faire une mode différente plus
inspirantes positive ça ça veut dire
aussi accepté l'imperfection
non on pourra pas tout faire
parfaitement mais on se retrousse les
manches on se dit ok entrepreneurs
pourquoi pas moi et on y va
c'est comme ça que j'ai créé ypsilon qui
est la première marque française de mode
féministe vote féministes pour moi ça
veut dire plusieurs choses avant tout
travailler sur le long terme sur l'image
des femmes
bien sûr ça passe par la représentation
des corps
évidemment pas de retouches se poser la
question de ce que je donne à voir
en tant que marque je vous parlais tout
à l'heure de mes problèmes de plis sur
le ventre j'ai découvert n'y a pas très
longtemps hashtag sur instagram qui
s'appelle embrace the squid très
littérale qui donc incite les femmes à
se prendre en photo avec leurs pistes
sur le ventre pour montrer les réalités
anatomiques en tant que féministe je
trouve ça génial et en tant que marque
je me dis si demain je fais un petit top
court l'été prochain et qui peut aussi
contribuer à travailler sur cette image
là tu perds on n'y va plus important
peut-être encore pour moi c'est aussi
sur le long terme
véhiculer l'idée que les mannequins et
les femmes en particulier ne sont pas là
juste pour faire joli
même dans la mode qu'elles ont des
histoires des opinions à partager c'est
pour ça que je ne casteret jamais une
femme pour son ventre plat ou happy
d'ailleurs mais pour ce qu'elle est et
pour ce qu'elle fait alors je vous parle
des femmes mais récemment j'ai fait
poser des hommes aussi avec ce pull girl
power
parce que je trouvais important de
véhiculer un message de montrer que en
le féminisme peut être porté par les
femmes mais aussi par des hommes
littéralement mais aussi porter leurs
convictions les interroger et faire des
interviews des portraits et là on est
plus sur le long terme on est dans
l'immédiat on est dans le quotidien et
le court terme la mode peut véhiculer un
message mais la mode vous laisse libre à
vous de choisir si vous avez envie de
voir un slogan cool si vous avez envie
d'avoir la curiosité de se demander
pourquoi la marque l'a fait est ce qu'il
ya une démarche derrière lire les
portraits la curiosité de parler à votre
voisin aussi la mode permet d'engager la
conversation
tiens pourquoi tu portes ce pull over
gender ça veut dire quoi je suis dans le
quotidien dans l'intimité des gens dans
leur armoire dans la rue c'est un médium
accessible qui permet de parler au plus
grand nombre tout en les laissant libres
la mode a une longue histoire de
changement de véhicule et quelque chose
mais c'était pas à la mode de dicter ce
que vous devez penser c'est le début
d'une conversation pour leur dis comme
ça être un game center dans son domaine
j'adorais de présenter comme ça c'est
super ça a l'air très clair à 100
la réalité c'est aussi que je suis
fatigué vraiment je suis fatigué je suis
fatigué de devoir constamment rentrer
dans une case de devoir choisir mon camp
et me justifier en permanence
côté business ça donne quelque chose à
peu près comme ça dans mes mademoiselle
c'est très bien on sent que vous êtes mû
par votre engagement votre combat mais
est-ce que vous êtes sûr que vous voulez
faire de l'argent parce que là on parle
business c'est pas une asso et côté
militant s'adonne parfois quelque chose
dans le genre
mais vous étiez féministes avant où ces
opportunistes
parce que quand même instrumentaliser
une cause pour faire de l'argent c'est
un peu limite et vous trouvez pas qu'il
ya des combats plus importants le viol
les inégalités salariales noir ou blanc
toujours noir je suis fatigué de me
battre contre la culture française
contre la culture du jugement a priori
avant même de pouvoir me battre pour mon
engagement avec mes moyens créatifs et
oui en montant une boîte je suis fatigué
mais je ne suis pas tout seul
je crois que nous sommes de plus en plus
nombreux à vouloir être entrepreneur est
aussi être des game center à vouloir
changer les choses dans la mode dans la
food dans l'éducation dans la santé à
remettre en cause cette culture oui
freddy française pourtant je le suis
aussi
j'ai moi aussi la révolution française
en héritage je suis une sans culotte
dans l'âme j'ai longtemps cru que le
changement se faisait le point levé ou
par la plume j'ai fait des débats j'ai
manifesté j'ai été en assaut j'ai dévoré
le panthéon féministe j'ai lu virginie
despentes king kong théorie et le
féminisme punk j'ai adoré je vous
conseille de lire d'ailleurs j'ai fait
du line in avec mes copines le féminisme
corporate de sheryl sandberg que je vous
conseille également
j'ai pris la parole et je continuerai à
prendre la parole temps qu'il faudra
mais je crois qu'il faut aussi passer
aux solutions et sortir de cet esprit
critique
moi aussi j'ai critiqué mais il ne faut
pas confondre esprit critique et
critique tout court j'aimerais qu'on
sorte de ce noir et blanc que
collectivement chacun fasse sa part avec
ses moyens
malheureusement soutenir une cause et
gagner de l'argent et encore mal perçus
alors je dis gagner de l'argent mais
c'est gagner de l'argent ou vouloir en
gagner parce que je rappelle que quand
vous montez une boîte au début en fait
vous gagnez pas de l'argent vous en
perdez d'ailleurs vous n'êtes même pas
sûrement gagner à la fin bon c'est un
investissement
c'est un coup de poker un pari qui a du
sens
non je ne serai jamais une licorne je me
définis souvent comme féministe
imparfaite je crois qu'il est temps de
dire que je suis aussi une entrepreneure
imparfaite que nous sommes
j'espère de plus en plus nombreux et des
entrepreneurs alors non pas un parfait
mais gagne schengen car je vous demande
une chose refusé d'être mis dans des
cases soyez des game challenger merci
[Applaudissements]